rents are due but no one is working and
that's just one of the practical
challenges that comes with shutting down
the global economy
fortunately socialist congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez has the
solution if you can figure out what
she's saying then speaking of not
speaking well Joe Biden proposes
postponing the Democratic National
Convention despite widespread fears that
time is not exactly on Joe's side we
will examine what the move would mean
for the Democratic Party all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the rent is too damn high and it's come
due it's the start of the month yet
unfortunately people have not been
working for weeks the New York Times is
reporting so take it with a grain of
salt but here I think they're probably
close to accurate that in New York City
upwards of 40% of people might not be
able to pay their rent this month I
believe that New York housing I've lived
in it for a while is very very expensive
and nobody makes enough money even
people who were investment bankers don't
make enough money and nobody's been
working for two or three weeks so
probably a good chance that a lot of New
Yorkers can't pay their rent this is
very stressful
this is very confusing luckily AOC is
here to clear it all up first we've got
to thank our friends over at fairway
meat market you know now more than ever
is a really good time to have food
delivered straight to your door so you
don't have to wait on long lines or go
through that kind of hassle fairway meat
market is so good fairway is a
family-owned grocery chain that has been
in business since 1938 I was on their
website shopping just yesterday they're
certified Dirac heritage pork is crafted
in small batches by Midwest family farms
making it the most succulent pork you
have ever tasted it is magnificent pork
I have that's probably my favorite thing
that they make but all the stuff is
really great all the steaks everything
visit fairway meat market calm select
your favorite product this week my
listeners can get the Heartland package
valued at $230 for just $99.99 good way
to save money and get food straight to
your door plus free shipping when
entering Knowles canna wles at check out
the Heartland package includes eight
8-ounce all-natural de rock boneless
pork chops six eight ounce USDA choice
ribeye steaks one mouth-watering side
dish loaded potato baked gourmet cheesy
corn or brisket baked beans that's more
than 50% off the best meat in America
Plus free shipping fairway meat market
kaam promo code Knowles look for the
heartland package that's fairway meat
market calm promo code Knowles look for
the heartland package you won't regret
it it is terrific so money is getting
really tight and now now really the
rubber meets the road because landlords
are expecting
rents and you got to live so what are we
gonna do we're of course we're gonna
turn to Alexandria Ocasio Cortez what
else would we do she is here to clear up
the whole situation for us as organized
a wrench strike that is okay you just
refusing to pay your rent is not
necessarily a wrench strike a rent
strike is an organized action which you
know I encourage you to research or
whatever if you're curious about that
but know that it's an organized action
it's not just like I'm a red stripe it's
it is a disciplined organized action and
to with you know concrete demands it
often requires organizing so make sure
you you know do that but you know
research them and and read about that if
that's something that you find you know
curious but okay I think I'm not sure
I'm getting this totally right but I
think and bear with me here I think it
has something to do with organizing and
action it's and so if you're if you're
curious and you want to organize action
like you want to take an action but
right now you're a little disorganized
what you should do is organize organize
your action and that way the action that
you enact will be organized that's
that's how you're gonna pay your rent I
guess you know if you're gonna be a
radical at least understand the radical
ideas you're proposing I go after Bernie
Sanders all the time Bernie Sanders is
wrong about everything what he wants to
do would breed nothing but misery
everywhere his ideas the ideas that he's
espousing have only bred misery
everywhere that they have been tried
however Bernie Sanders at least knows
what the radical ideas are that he's
proposing aoc can't even explain what
the rent strike is as she's proposing a
rent strike or at least in encouraging a
rent strike so she doesn't get there
with this she's incredibly making Joe
Biden look lucid and articulate which is
a rare occurrence she doesn't know what
she's talking about and compounding the
problem her ideology doesn't make any
sense in the first place there is
actually a moment though in this very
long livestream where a OC drops the
ideology for a second and actually
addresses the question which is how are
people gonna pay their rents when they
don't have any money coming in all in
all just have the honest conversation
with your landlord if you need just a
break if you need five hundred dollars
being in a thousand dollars if you can't
pay at all have that conversation but
know that in the state of New York
Tobin was called for a mortgage
moratorium they can talk to their bank
and have that discussion with them hey
that was actually not a terrible idea
this might be breaking news I think it's
the first time I've ever suggested that
something IOC said is not a terrible
idea but it's true which was she saying
you don't have enough money to pay your
rent this month something like six
million people are about to be
unemployed if they're not unemployed
already right so there are a lot of
people who can't pay their rent this
month
landlords understand that they're in the
same tanked economy that we all are
because of this damned Chinese pandemic
so what are you gonna do you don't have
the cash so I guess you just talk to
your landlord say hey landlord I'm
really sorry but we're all in this
global pandemic and economic collapse so
I don't have the money that's your best
shot of figuring out a solution probably
your landlord is going to be somewhat
understanding but by the way in your
landlords defense it's not like they're
just all flush with cash swimming and
you know $100 bills in their swimming
pools they need money too because
they've got to pay the bank so what
she's saying is we'll talk to the banks
because the government state government
the federal government are working with
banks to try to ease this problem
actually not a bad idea now you know
that was about six seconds out of the
whole video started to make sense then
unfortunately aoc stops making sense
again but also I think it's part of a
larger conversation about capitalism
because a lot of people's main income
to do with just owning property which
you know there are some elements of it
where like if you are doing repairs and
all these other things it's it's a
nuanced conversation but um it's you
know it's it's it's an area that a lot
of that exposes a lot of income and
socio-economic inequity so um you know
there's so much there there but I'm
gonna move on to the next question but
that doesn't mean it's it's not an
unimportant conversation so there is a
lot of there there when we're talking
about the role of ownership and renting
in an economy there is not a lot of
there there in a o'seas answer obviously
cuz she just kind of runs out of steam
actually this is another comparison to
Joe Biden Joe Biden in his debate
performances he'll start talking and
then he'll just lose his train of
thought and say well okay never mind
anyway my times up
that's kind of what ALC did here said in
anyway it's the rent and this inequality
and capitalism and economics and big
conversation but she can't get into the
conversation cuz she doesn't know what
she's talking about it would appear from
this stream that she is against rent in
general right I mean that's what she's
saying it's a big conversation
inequalities and you can't we got to
talk about how bad this is in general
well if you're against rent just in
principle then what do you say to people
who don't have enough money to afford
their own home or to afford their own
land that they own which is most people
right most people can't just go out and
buy a nice house on a random Tuesday
afternoon you have to rent for some time
at least how is that gonna work what are
those people gonna do the reason we have
rent in the first place is for people
who don't have all the cash to go buy a
home or to go buy land but they need
somewhere to stay is her suggestion then
that well people should not be
landowners or building owners you know
she says it's terrible that she
insinuates at least but it's terrible
that some people make money by renting
out property so
if we've established that people need to
rent property right they need not
everyone can afford it is the government
just supposed to own all the property
actually as part of a se screen New Deal
the government does take a much greater
interest in property because they force
every single building in America to be
redone according to their new standards
so in essence the federal government is
taking over a lot of property but even
in that case even if the government owns
all the property and they're renting it
to all the rest of us they're still rent
right there's still the government
making money on everybody else's labor
which is the problem that she's
identifying in rent but I guess the
government exclusively makes money on
everybody else's labor I see some flaws
in her ideology AOC doesn't understand
the problem she's trying to solve she
just looks at rent she says oh those
people are paying money to that guy the
landowner but he's not doing anything
that I can vit see and they are all
going to their jobs every day so that's
bad not not recognizing that the guy who
owns the property has to keep up the
property has to pay property taxes that
probably has some other properties too
maybe he's a little bit levered up maybe
he's making a lot of housing available
to people but he doesn't have a ton of
money himself maybe the people he's
renting to have a higher income than he
does she knows that she wants to destroy
this idea of renting it's kind of like
Chesterton's fence you know you see the
fence in the middle of the road the
radical reformer just wants to get rid
of it because he can't see the point of
it and the wise reformer says no no no
you've got to understand what it's for
before I'll even consider letting you
destroy it she she just she doesn't
understand even the question much less
the answer the whole exchange reminded
me of the greatest rent focused
politician and candidate ever in
American history that would be Jimmy
McMillan if the rent is too damn high
party
Jimmy who ran for governor of New York
against Andy Cuomo the current governor
of New York all the way back I think
this was 2010 and he made a whole lot
more sense on the subject of rent than
aoc people working 8 hours a day and 40
hours a week or some a third job
women can't afford to take hit the
children feed the children breakfast
lunch and dinner my main job is to
provide a roof over your head food on
the table and money in your pocket
this is politics as usual playing the
silly game it's not going to happen go
read to them Maya move me to people I'm
here to represent can't afford to pay
the rent they're being laid off right
now without speak they can't eat
breakfast lunch or dinner listen
someone's stomach chill child's stomach
just growled did you hear it you gotta
listen like me okay let's talk about the
issue mr. thirty seconds for you sir
Rick as a karate expert I will not talk
about anyone up here because our
children can't afford to live anywhere
nowhere there's nowhere to go once again
why you said it to rent it's too damn
the rent is too damn high a OC should
take notes from Jimmy who I should note
is a very longtime friend of mine there
I've knocked Jimmy for probably ten
years now and we've done different
campaign things together and there's
actually one video on the Internet of I
was over at Jimmy's apartment and I was
there with sweet little Lisa back we
were still dating and it's a video of
sweet little Lisa on Jimmy's couch and
Jimmy playing a guitar with a silhouette
of his face on it and it's a singing a
song about a homeless guy and how you
react to homeless guys it's actually a
profound profound song there's a there's
a lot of profundity and entertainment
obviously to what Jimmy has to say
unfortunately that kind of profundity
it's just not there for dear old aoc and
speaking of inarticulate Democratic
candidates AOC is vying for the top spot
with Joe Biden the presumptive
Democratic presidential nominee Joe
Biden made some news yesterday this was
not a flub the only time he's ever in
the newspapers these days is because he
said something that just makes no sense
at all and and shows signs of his
cognitive decline Joe Biden was on MSNBC
he was on a show with Brian Williams and
he suggested after a lot of pushback
from the Democratic Party he suggested
that the Democrats postpone their
National Convention for coronavirus
and you really envisioned every
prominent Democrat in this country from
all 50 states inside a hot arena 104
days from now it's hard to envision that
again we should listen to the scientist
and you know one of the reasons why the
Democratic convention was going to be
held early was the Olympics were coming
after the Republican convention there is
more time now I think we're gonna get we
have that we ought to be able to do we
were able to do a middle of the Civil
War all the way through to world war ii
have have Democratic and Republican
conventions and primaries and elections
and still have Public Safety there it is
and you can trust Joe Biden's opinion on
this because Joe Biden was around during
the Civil War
okay he was around during World War two
he remembers what it was like to have
those conventions so he's got a lot of
credibility on this issue party leaders
were pushing back against this very
strongly up until Joe Biden came out and
said it now the Democrats are starting
to get on board but it's no small
decision to move the Democratic National
Convention it actually is a microcosm or
a just a good example of the problems in
the economy generally the Democratic
National Convention right now is
supposed to run July 13th to 16th so
you're asking you telling me we're not
gonna be done with coronavirus by
mid-july I got plans man I got stuff to
do well that's what Biden and the
Democrats seem to be saying it's
supposed to be held to accommodate 4750
delegates plus thousands of other party
officials and reporters and activists
and corporate sponsors so it's a lot of
people in one place you remember at the
very beginning of the corona virus
outbreak that happened to coincide with
CPAC the Conservative Political Action
Conference where I was speaking and a
lot of other conservatives were speaking
and one guy had coronavirus and that one
guy happened to be backstage when I was
there with senator Cruz and RNC
chairwoman Rhonda McDaniel and Kellyanne
Conway and the
the Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos
and just a ton of people in the
government and all of a sudden like
everybody's got to go quarantine because
there was this one guy there were
probably ten thousand twenty thousand
people at the whole conference
fortunately by the way I don't think a
lot of people from CPAC got it you only
heard about that one guy but still
everybody got so nervous senator Cruz
quarantined Rhonda McDaniel quarantined
a lot of people were nervous because
they met a guy who met a guy who met a
guy who had the corona virus can you
imagine what that would be like at the
Democratic National Convention that
would be not not great especially when
you're presumptive nominee is right in
the target group of people who can be
vulnerable to corona virus so this could
cost millions of dollars you know
speaking of the rent is too damn high if
you were to cancel this convention that
which which you know just to compare it
to 2016 2016 s Democratic convention
generated 231 million dollars for
Philadelphia so who knows how much this
one would generate that could lead to
millions of millions of dollars of lost
revenue what does this show it shows one
that our economy it's just extremely
vulnerable right now because we ground
the thing to a halt for now what three
weeks it's gonna be a month and a half
at least by the time this is over it
also shows that Joe Biden is being
treated as the de facto head of the
Democratic Party for some time you had
the DNC chairman Tom Perez saying that
AOC is the future of the party this
young radical but now it's right back to
old Joe Biden okay Joe Biden who's been
around forever who's been in he was in
the Senate in the 70s in the early 70s
and he was vice president we just known
him forever
that guy is in charge now he's calling
the shots the party's against moving the
convention he's for it guess what
they're gonna do they're gonna move the
convention very unclear what this means
for the party though in 2020 you know if
you would ask three weeks ago what this
means that Joe Biden is now the head of
the Democratic Party I would say that it
means that Democrats have their best
shot at beating Trump all of the polls
were showing us and I think including
the Trump internal polling that Bernie
Sanders was a bigger threat to Donald
Trump
then Joe Biden or rather vice versa I
just pulled a Biden that Joe Biden is a
bigger threat than Bernie Sanders now I
don't know I just don't know who do you
want in a time of crisis do you want a
guy who can't remember his own name do
you want a guy who's been in politics
for so long and totally ineffective a
guy who lost in 1988 a guy who lost in
2008 a guy who never really accomplished
much except except for the 1994 crime
bill which he's now running away from do
you want that guy or do you want someone
who's vigorous energetic clearly lucid
holding hours along daily press
conferences where he's answering
reporters questions on everything from
military action in you know in China or
in the Middle East or wherever to this
pandemic response to the stimulus bill
to infrastructure well we'll get to the
presser in a moment because this one
actually was probably even more
newsworthy than yesterday's who do you
want obviously you'll you'll want to go
with Trump and yet can a president get
reelected if there's 20% unemployment I
don't think we've ever seen that before
so it's just totally up in the air I
mean we are now in unchartered territory
Trump by the way is no longer playing
defense and I think this is very
important initially I was worried that
the Democrats were using coronavirus yet
again as a way to put Trump on defense
you know that's that's what they've been
doing Trump has been trying to plow
through his agenda and so the Democrats
are just trying to impede that first
with the Russia hoax so they impede him
from doing anything even if the Russia
hoax comes to nothing even though Muller
finds absolutely nothing it impedes him
in a way from completing his agenda in
the first couple years then they try to
impeach him they know that he's never
gonna be removed from office but they
just do it to slow him down they just do
it to put him on defense so they're
answering so that he's answering their
questions it's kind of like if you ask a
guy hey when did you stop beating your
wife it will stop him in his tracks
because there's no correct answer to
that if you say oh I haven't done that
he'll say you haven't stopped beating
your wife no no I I don't I'm not doing
that well when did you stop when
obviously you did it in the first place
they've been trying to do this for his
whole presidency but now Trump is
proactively working to affect his agenda
even in the face of the virus so
yesterday during the press briefing he
moves on
just from the strict questions of the
pandemic and the spread and social
distancing to get to something he's a
lot more interested in and that is
stopping Mexican drug cartels from
crossing the border here's President
Trump as governments and nations focus
on the coronavirus there's a growing
threat that cartels criminals terrorists
and other malign actors will try to
exploit this situation for their own
gain and we must not let that happen we
will never let that happen
today the United States is launching
enhanced counter narcotics operations in
the Western Hemisphere to protect the
American people from the deadly scourge
of illegal narcotics we must not let the
drug cartels exploit the pandemic to
threaten American lives in cooperation
with the 22 partner nations u.s.
Southern Command will increase
surveillance disruption and seizures of
drug shipments and provide additional
support for eradication efforts which
are going on right now at a record pace
we're deploying additional Navy
destroyers combat ships aircraft and
helicopters Coast Guard cutters and air
force surveillance aircraft doubling our
capabilities in the region I love this
answer and he goes on it's actually
worth watching at least that portion of
the press conference the left has been
making the coronavirus narrative work
for them okay the left has been using
the corona virus in many cases alarmism
and hysteria to work for them to try to
institute massive government regulations
massive government spending ubi for
goodness sakes direct checks to the
american people at least in a limited
way they're trying to push for medicare
for all through this virus they're using
the corona virus to push their their
agenda some
more successfully than other times
sometimes you can tie it directly to the
virus they can questions of health care
and sometimes you can't do that like in
trying to reduce airplane emissions that
doesn't make a lot of sense but there's
still to try to use the narrative to
push their agenda now President Trump is
playing that game on his own he is also
using the coronavirus narrative to push
his agenda but at least when Trump is
doing it it does have a direct
connection to stopping the pandemic
frankly even if it didn't I would cheer
him on because at least he's getting
something through as the Democrats have
impeded him now for four years but it is
tied directly to it what are we talking
about we're talking about open borders
you know right now there is a chance
that the state of New York will have to
close its border and not be able to come
in and infect the rest of the country so
surely we should close our border with
foreign countries you know the left-wing
press even has been reporting that
they're nervous about cases of
coronavirus in Mexico now they're
reporting it because they're simply
nervous about it in Mexico per se but if
we have a completely porous border with
Mexico then obviously people who have
grown a virus could get over here into
the United States
you cannot simultaneously say that the
corona virus is so serious that we need
to border off wolof New York State but
we don't need to wall off Mexico okay
that that does not work so Trump is is
making that argument next part of this
is because there's economic collapse
always drug use goes through the roof
during recessions during economic crisis
we're already seeing 70,000 people per
year dying from drug overdoses because
of the opioid epidemic most people on
the Left don't want to talk about that
that number can only get worse during an
economic downturn and so Trump is saying
it is vital to the public health that we
stop these drug cartels from using our
porous border to bring poison into our
country as the left is pushing for
legalization of drugs almost across the
board certainly at the low level and
some people are pushing for it generally
some Democratic presidential candidates
we're pushing for the legalization of
all drugs Trump is saying are you crazy
you can't that that would be such a
a threat would so exacerbate these
public health challenges if we did that
right now as the opioid problem is only
poised to get worse he's tying it into
the military because as we are weakened
as we're hunkering down bad actors
around the world including the jerks who
gave us the damn disease China or and
who covered it up and who were solely
responsible for the things spreading
around the world are going to be looking
around and seeing if they can take
advantage of us militarily unfortunately
our Secretary of Defense Mark Esper is
on the case and he's not gonna let that
happen
last year alone United States southern
commands operations resulted in the
seizure of over 280 metric tons of drugs
much of which was designated for
shipment to America while this was an
incredible achievement there is much
more work to be done
transnational criminal organizations
continue to threaten our security by
smuggling cocaine fentanyl
methamphetamines and other narcotics
across our borders these drug
traffickers put our communities
communities at risk and destroy lives
every year tens of thousands of
Americans die from drug overdose and
thousands more suffer the harmful
effects of addiction you see this this
is the Secretary of Defense so he does
touch on later in the show other foreign
policy threats that we've got but he
keeps focusing in on these international
criminal organizations the cartels and
the drugs he's going back to the 70,000
people per year die from drugs general
mark Milley chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff echoed this same point
explicitly mentioned 70,000 people per
year dying from drugs in the US Attorney
General Bill Bar comes up there echoes
the same point 70,000 people per year
dying from drugs in the United States
this is a key point here because one
reason that some people have overreacted
to the corona virus epidemic who have
become panicked or who have just really
worried themselves to death is because
we don't remember that people die in the
United States most people don't know
that between 30 and 70 thousand people
die from the flu each year most people
don't know that 38,000 people die in car
accidents certainly people don't know
that 70,000 people die from drug
overdoses and so when we hear numbers
like maybe 50,000 or 100,000 people will
die from corona virus or more 200,000
people
will die from coronavirus then we get
shocked by that we say that's such a
shocking number it's unprecedented and
so what they're driving home is actually
guys we see these numbers all the time
and we're not taking any action to stop
them so I think it's a great use of
resources right now one because if we
stop these drugs from coming over that
actually will help the public health
specifically with regard to coronavirus
but it will make the broader point as
well so speaking of our open border a
reporter asked President Trump in this
briefing why he isn't giving any
stimulus money to illegal aliens and you
might expect that Trump would use this
opportunity to just slam dunk on the
reporter but he doesn't his answer was a
lot more measured and a lot wiser than
that over five million immigrants in
this country do pay taxes through their
ID numbers yet they will not receive any
money in their stimulus package I know
undocumented immigrant who received any
aid from the government during this
crisis how do you suppose they survive
during the culprit nineteen well you
know you're seeing undocumented meaning
they came in illegally and a lot of
people would say we have a lot of
citizens right now that won't be working
so what are you going to do it's a tough
thing it's a very terrible it's a very
sad question I must be honest with you
but they came in illegally and we have a
lot of people that are citizens of our
country that won't be able to have jobs
now I do think once we get rid of the
virus I think we're gonna have a boom
economy I think it's gonna go up rather
quickly maybe very quickly and maybe
slowly but it's gonna go up
and it'll all come back and I think it's
actually going to come back stronger
than what it was because of the stimulus
but it's it's a really sad situation and
we are working on it I will tell you I'm
not gonna give you a hard and fast
answer because I just want to tell you
it's something I think about and it's
something we're working on I really
liked this answer because the premise is
absurd
you know the premises hey when six
million Americans are out of work why
are we giving more handouts to illegal
aliens who flout our laws and cross over
into our country and use our resources
right so that
it's a crazy question it'd be so easy to
slam dunk on it but Trump doesn't slam
her because the simple fact is
everything about coronavirus is sad
that's that the effect on people's
health is sad the effect on the economy
is sad the effect on our rights is sad
and the effect on the illegal aliens is
sad you know most people the vast
majority of people who cross into this
country illegally do so so that they can
make money they want to advance
themselves economically they want to
have a better life it is not in the vast
majority of cases it is not because
they're fleeing political or religious
persecution as refugees it's simply
because their economic migrants who want
to make more money fair enough
I get it if I came from a terrible
country I would want to go somewhere
else and make some more money - now of
course we can't do that we can't just
open our borders and take everybody in
on the one hand it's illegal you know we
the people have a right to govern our
country and decide who comes in and who
who doesn't and we have the most
generous economic raishin system in the
world but also it's just impossible you
cannot take everybody from the entire
world and put them in the United States
still it's very sad you know it's sad
that people with very little who have
come here now have even less because of
China because China unleashed this
plague onto the entire world and it's
sad that they'll have fewer resources
then American citizens sad for them you
know it doesn't mean that we need to
open our borders and give them a ton of
resources when six million Americans are
gonna be out of work they committed the
crime they have to deal with the
consequences but I like the Trump is
showing sympathy here because it
undercuts the leftist argument these
heartless and it shows the pernicious
effects of illegal immigration this is
what happens
Democrats created that particular
problem and and some open borders
Republicans created that problem and
it's still showing strong leadership you
know we cannot tolerate the open border
then before we get to mail bag
there was one pretty telling exchange
here and the exchange has to do with the
exchanges the exchange has to do with
the Obamacare exchanges a reporter asks
vice president Mike Pence why don't you
just reopen the Obamacare exchanges to
deal with people who don't have how
insurance right now there are a lot of
people who are worried about getting
sick and do they end up in a hospital
people who are uninsured and will they
be crushed by medical bills you were
considering last month last month
already in March reopening the
healthcare.gov exchanges there has been
a determination not to do that could you
tell us what the rationale was behind
that and and what what you have is an
alternative okay they took that up under
the task force and make maybe my well
thank you mr. president and what I can
tell you is that the president has made
a priority from the outset of our task
force work make sure every American
knows that they can have a corona virus
and they don't have to worry about the
cost we were very inspired as well
because of the president's engagement
with the leading health insurance
companies in the country that now so far
two of the top health insurance
companies in America have announced that
they're not only willing to waive
co-pays on testing and now testing is
fully covered because of the bill the
President signed for every American but
also there these two insurance companies
have waived co-pays on all coronavirus
treatment
okay now pence has to be careful here
because you don't you want to provide
relief but you don't want to indicate a
left-wing policy agenda the next
question that leftists are asking is
okay well if free stuff and universal
health care is good enough for
coronavirus why can't we have it all the
time why can't we just get Bernie style
socialist medicine now the answer is
that Bernie wants to emulate the
political and healthcare systems of Cuba
and Venezuela and if we do that then
we're going to end up like Cuban
Venezuela and we won't be able to give
health care to anybody anyway we're not
going to not forget global leadership we
won't even be able to provide for our
own people so that's one answer on it
but at the same time we are we are
giving people relief right now because
we happen to be a very rich country and
we're able to afford that so what is the
answer okay what is the answer that
we're just gonna let poorer Americans
die in the street of course not Mike
Pence gives an excellent answer on this
when he's pressed on it we will get to
that in a second first I've got to thank
our friends
for at you I got to thank you if you
have not had a chance to see some of our
new content called all-access live then
you should head on over to daily
wire.com and check it out we're gonna
keep that going all this week at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific it's a great
show it's really just we're hanging out
with you this was meant for our
all-access members but during isolation
we are opening it up to all of our
members so if you're not a member yet
head on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe and we'll see you at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific don't go
anywhere we got a lot more including the
mailbag coming right up
so what are we gonna do about this
healthcare problem are we gonna do like
the left-wing premise always suggests
are we gonna let poor people die in the
street in America no we're not going to
do that and Mike Pence gives a very good
answer I thought when he was pressed on
it there will be people who don't have
insurance who get sick before any of
these mitigation efforts are put into
place and without opening the health
care exchanges where can they find
insurance people who aren't insured by
these companies that are covering the
cost of the copay where can people go
now to get health insurance if they get
sick before these well all across
America we have Medicaid for
underprivileged Americans I think that's
a great answer people the left forgets
this they said what are we going to do
for people who can't afford health
insurance who are on the lowest end of
the income and wealth scale as if we
don't already have an answer to that
that's the point of Medicaid they that
is that is what Medicaid is now what the
left might say to that is well Medicaid
is very low quality care you want to
just give them Medicaid and the correct
response to that is you want to give
everybody Medicaid your what Medicare
for all right medic but Medicare for all
would just be Medicaid for all right
it's just saying a government-run health
care system if the quality is no good
then why on earth would we give that to
every single person and force them to
have that kind of health care the left
always does this they they push and they
push and say once and for all we've got
to end the health care problem on it
from poor people we've got to in the
health care problem for this group for
that group for this group and then they
they get their bills passed and then
what you rember what Obamacare was
supposed to give us all universal health
care that was the point of Obamacare and
now they're complaining as though
Obamacare never happened because it
because Obamacare didn't work very well
we got Medicaid right it's good to have
Medicaid for people who can't afford
health care now they're complaining that
Medicaid is no good well okay then I
sure as hell don't want it then why
would you expand that program to
everybody now I thought it was a good
answer president Trump disagreed
apparently he did not think it was a
good answer he actually made fun of
vice-president pence for not directly
answering the reporter's question we'll
get
this using the full weight of the
federal government and the full strength
of the American economy for so though
and it's something we're really gonna
look at because it doesn't seem fair if
you have it you have a big advantage and
it's a certain income level you do I
think it's one of the greatest answers
I've ever heard because Mike was able to
speak for five minutes and not even
touch these words no no I said that's
what you call a great profession and
it's something we're looking at
absolutely brutal he's just a mean cab
for the guy right after his answer very
funny but certainly brutal from a
traditional political perspective this
would seem to hurt Trump because he's
undercutting his own guys and his own
administration but actually I think this
is what makes him charming is he just
doesn't care he doesn't stick to the
script okay and part of the reason that
President Trump not sticking to the
script works is that everyone else in
his administration does stick to the
script and they rounded out this presser
that's the last point before we get to
the mailbag they rounded out this
presser by linking the virus to the key
aspect of President Trump's policy
agenda they link it to that big
beautiful wall that Trump has been
promising us for five years did you talk
about how tight that southern border is
right now absolutely we have continued
to build miles of the wall every day
we're up to over 150 I believe we're
continuing to build new new miles of law
and a lot of folks asked about
replacement wall or new miles and it's a
new capability on our southwest border
that we haven't had before so whether
you talk to the agents the Border Patrol
agents they like that capability like
they like that impedance and denial that
it provides them and it provides the
ability for those agents to focus
elsewhere on parts of the border that
are very difficult to patrol so we can
use our resources in a different way
this is key first it's important that
president from can show progress on the
wall before his reelection right this
was a key part of his 2016 campaign if
he can't show progress on it that's not
going to look good to his base second
though it's important that Trump
controls the narrative
on the virus okay and so far I think
they've done a good job on this because
the virus has vindicated the Trump
policy agenda its vindicated Trump on
China on relying on the supply chain
from China when everybody virtually
everybody in both parties made fun of
him for making such a big deal about
having manufacturing in China not being
tough enough on China guess what turns
out he was right it vindicates him on
open borders again when many people in
the Republican Party as well as the
Democratic Party we're saying open
borders not a big deal we need amnesty
we need path to citizenship we need to
create more incentives for people to
cross over now we're learning open
borders are not so great especially in a
global pandemic okay and it it
vindicates him on drugs on the drug
issue that a lot of people were not
focusing on now we're right in the thick
of it vindicates so much of this agenda
this globalization generally they've got
to keep focused on that that's the only
way that they can take this crisis which
is really bad and really does back them
into a corner I mean if if the worst
part is the economic you know even if
we're just talking about the economic
side of it really bad for Trump's
reelection chances they've got to take
that from from backing them into a
corner and use it to show that it's
actually vindicating what they've been
doing the whole time all right I'm
usually typically running late but let's
try to get through some mailbag from
Nick obviously we're in the middle of a
crisis the crisis of not knowing which
show to watch next while quarantined any
movies documentaries or serious UN SLA
suggest watching the obvious answer one
of the greatest works of documentary
film ever made
Tiger King just started watching it last
night
it's magnificent that one's great I'm
watching succession right now is really
good really really good the acting is
superb the writing is superb it's a
really great show and I've been going
through some old movies too I you know I
had actually never seen the man who shot
Liberty valance it's great Jimmy Stewart
John Wayne movie directed by John Ford
what a magnificent film you can get it
on Amazon Prime for free just an amazing
film profound subtle especially for that
era of film which was not always
terribly subtle really subtle about
of the West what that means and the
relationship between exploration and
settling and the law and civilization
just and well what an amazing movie I
wish so I mean it's considered one of
the great classics of film and I can't
believe I didn't see it until now
just watch Sunset Boulevard a little
while ago another just magnificent film
that's pretty old and people don't watch
as much anymore great movies so much
great stuff to watch once you have
finished watching all of the Michael
Noel's show verdict with Ted Cruz and
the Prager Prager you book-club show
from Alana dear Michael I'm not a person
who takes relationships lightly and I
have been dating this guy for a little
while now
things have been going perfectly even
though we're in a long-distance
relationship and quarantined I feel so
loved and appreciated the problem lies
in our ideological differences I'm a
devout Christian
my boyfriend was raised Mormon he parted
with his church in his teens and is now
agnostic preferring spiritualist ideas
such as shared consciousness or Buddhism
oh he knows how important my faith is
and I know that he respects it in me but
when I think about how I want to raise
my kids in the future I know that I need
a partner as devout as I am who will
instill strong conservative values which
he just not share my question is is this
worth continuing my relationship with
someone I've fallen in love with despite
our differences or am I wasting my time
love the show thanks depends how old you
are the different answers depending on
how old you are if you're you know 16
then maybe let it play out for a little
bit if you're 18 or 20 I don't know if
you're 30 or 35 then the the timeline
gets a little tighter doesn't it I mean
it kind of depends where you fall on
that scale I've entertained all sorts of
crazy religious ideas in my life you
know I would have called myself an
atheist for probably 10 years and I
might have even fallen into that awful
trap that Millennials fall into where
they say I'm spiritual but not religious
it's like the most popular religion
among Millennials right now and I get it
I probably would have said it myself
except what that really means is I'm not
that curious about the objective nature
of the world and of God or creator but I
am very interested in myself you know
find my
very interesting so whatever that's just
a dumb idea that's become very popular
it's not necessarily his fault with that
you've got to see if he can move on over
because you know if you are gonna raise
your kids Christian then he's got to get
on board with that and if he's not gonna
get on board with that then you might
have to move on no matter how much
affection that you have for one another
but if if time is on your side and if
he's open minded and and do you think
you can talk through these things and
he's curious then I would I would maybe
consider letting that play out too I
mean he's already gone for Mormonism to
this kind of vague agnosticism which
means he was disenchanted with the
Mormon Church but that disenchantment
might might fall away after a while he
might become curious again and ask these
questions he might be searching and he
might find an answer that's more
amenable to your point of view from
Michael hi Pedro Knowles why is the
panic over can't come flu so much higher
than swine flu swine flu infected 60
million yet we did not shut down the
economy thanks you know I think the
reason is that we just have no idea what
the cure for this would be well part of
the reason is because Donald Trump is
president and the Democrats don't want
him to be re-elected so the media are
willing to gin this up and create
hysteria and talk about how two million
Americans are gonna die when the models
don't really show that but the other
part of the reason is we know what a
swine flu is we knew what a swine flu
was so even though it killed a lot of
people fifteen thousand people or so we
knew how to handle it whereas for this
we don't have a vaccine and we only
recently discovered a treatment that
looks promising so to give them that the
the alarmists the benefit of the doubt I
think that's part of what it is but
people who are still pushing outdated
hysterical numbers that's clearly just
political from Michael hello mr. Knowles
I've been tremendously enjoying your new
show the book club on Prager you and
recently finished reading man's search
for meaning by Viktor Frankl after
hearing about it in your first episode
with Dennis while reading the book I was
intrigued to hear that Viktor Frankl
said we can't pursue happiness but that
must ensue as an unintended side effect
of being devoted to a higher cause does
this contradict the Declaration of
Independence
which says that we have a right to
pursue happiness well they're talking
about different things here I mean in
the Declaration Thomas Jefferson is
talking about natural rights and is he's
invoking john locke here who says we
have a right to life liberty and
property and he's saying the pursuit of
happiness you want you want to give
people too many wrong impressions about
having a right to own property we don't
have a right to be given property by
other people that we have a right to
possess the property that we have and so
he uses this phrase the pursuit of
happiness but I think it's imprecise and
I think probably Viktor Frankl is is
telling you something more profound
there which is that you can't just say I
really want to be happy I mean people do
this all the time at holidays they'll
they'll very often say you know I just
want this Thanksgiving to be really good
and they try so hard to have a good time
and they don't it's why Valentine's Day
is almost always miserable as people are
so invested in making it perfect and
just you know the the ideal day that
nothing could live up to that and they
end up miserable you can't do that you
have to be pursuing the good and then
happiness my cut will will come
alongside that or joy will come
alongside that but if you're just
pursuing this emotion of being happy
you're not going to get it last question
from Kanan hey I'm currently reading the
Divine Comedy and I just finished the
inferno I was wondering if you think the
real Hell will have such creative
punishments tailored for specific sins
thanks great question so one key aspect
of Dante especially in Hell or Dante in
ferony is that the punishment fits the
crime so maybe the most famous canto is
about Paolo and Francesca these
adulterous lovers who are swept away on
the wind that's their eternal punishment
they're just swept constantly away in
the wind they have no control over where
they're going because adulterous lovers
are slaves to their own passions they
can't control where they're going
they're swept away on the winds of lust
the punishment fits the crime the
suicides people who commit suicide are
in hell and their bodies have been
transformed into these sort of trees
your bodies hanging from branches and
they don't they don't have their own
because they threw away their body in
their own lives the punishment fits the
crime this is certainly true of eternal
justice if it's true of our own justice
it's true eternal justice and generally
people get what they're after you know
people get get what they want you know
there was a natural consequence to our
actions and so I think Dante illustrates
that beautifully and precisely all right
that's our show we got more to get to
but you know we're already running late
so have a good weekend we'll have some
other fun stuff coming out over the
weekend so stay tuned
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Noel's show see you at
least on Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
whanau ski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there